[Music]
welcome to this afternoon's session
migrating to cloud spanner my name is
Sammy xuer Dean I'm a stop solution
architect with Google cloud joined today
by Neal from across the pond we're both
gonna spend the next 45 50 minutes with
you going over all kinds of scenarios on
migrating from digital tape archives to
cloud spanner just kidding we're not
going to talk about digital tape
archives cause spanner hopefully that's
a different talk if you need that talk
talk to me afterwards so most likely are
coming from much more contemporary
frameworks much more interesting
database choices and really what we want
to do today is talk about that I'm going
to talk about cloud spanner if you hear
hopefully that's because something
externally enticed you to want to look
at where the migration would look like
but we'll go over real quick what the
background is on cloud spanner and why
you would want to consider it we'll talk
about in general how we've thought about
migrations and how Neil and I have put
together sort of a sequence of steps
that we think applies to most
organizations in the way that they are
going to approach a migration but we
really want to make it practical for you
we've chosen a couple case studies that
we'll walk through step by step and show
how you would go from a source system
into cloud spanner so hopefully you will
leave here with something tangible and
then finally we'll wrap up with some
closing thoughts
hopefully that sounds fair so quick
background on cloud spanner its
internally used within Google as spanner
it is our transactional record of State
for hundreds of applications and it was
born not sort of in the beginning and
the beginning Google was busy solving
how to interact the it index the
internet and sort of find all these
massive patterns and provide meaningful
search and it wasn't something that was
initially tackled until it became
critical that we did tackle it based on
the size of some of our businesses but
what we did realized a lot of challenges
that we were overcoming are faced by a
lot of organizations how do you at scale
maintain a database with high
reliability high durability
transactional throughput something that
can be used in financial transaction
and so cloud spanner is the
externalization of that we realize a lot
of customers have the same challenges
and have gone down different paths to
try to solve it so if you are coming
from that sort of hey broad broad use of
data but I've had to make trade-offs in
the past had to decide on what you were
willing to give up
hopefully this talk will be applicable
to you it's enterprise-grade google uses
it to run a multi-billion dollar
enterprise we have other customers using
it as well
but really it's designed with a high SLA
in mind to be strictly consistent it is
acid compliant and it's distributed it's
the thing that a lot of organizations
try to challenge try to solve with
distributed architectures with a multi
server approach with multi nodes with a
lot of interconnect and a lot of
district distributed storage it is all
that but instead it's just a database
behind an API it gives you all that
distributed nature but you don't really
have to do much to get through to it
it's relational in nature so relational
data is sort of like the easiest thing
to get your head around if you've been
around databases it's been around for a
very long time it's something anybody's
can sort of reason about when they go
from one team to our another within
Google we value developer time
considerably and it doesn't make a lot
of sense to have developers move from
one team to another and sort of have to
say well what stores are using how we're
using it what are their canonical
queries everybody sort of gets sequel
and gets a relational model pretty well
and so there's a very little low
friction point to move salient lis
between teams and say oh yeah I know
you're using spanner at the back end I
can get going on that
and it's horizontally scalable it's not
much it's not this sort of heavy-handed
you can scale up but you can't scale
down and it's not where you have to make
a capacity request history you kind of
poke an API and you get a lot more
transactional throughput through to it
just spin it up it's pretty simple you
name the instance choose a region pick a
number of nodes and hit create I just
wanted to show that cuz up that was
pretty cool animation all right I didn't
make it so really you just have to
reason about two things and then I'll
turn it over to
in naming and computer science is
everything right so name you have to
name it but then you have to pick how
many nodes nodes is really just your
unit of capacity it is the most
sensitive thing to cost you pick how
many nodes you need and we'll go through
kind of what each node gives you in a
little bit and then where do you want it
so how much capacity do you want and
where do you want it which region do you
want multi region the product comes in a
lot of different varieties and the last
thing is take your code merge it
together with our client libraries or
speak sequel to us and then you're ready
to go
we understand DDL as a database so
things that are used to doing in other
databases are pretty easy to use similar
like bigquery and other products there's
a built-in query window so that's the
basic it really takes what I describe
takes longer than it and then it
actually does to actually get started
with cloud spanner so now let's talk
about migrations how we're going to talk
about the rest of it
the programs are going to walk through
in terms of the migration practical
examples Neil's going to talk through
that so hi my name is no Mark Richt I'm
a solution architect from Belgium and so
in this section I'm going to give a
general framework for migrations giving
you a high-level plan of action for
migrating your application from the
existing database to cloud spanner
so the first step you need to isolate
all your database access code if you got
it distribute in various modules in your
application including in any any lines
of code it's best to isolate that all
into a separate module and that will be
the one place where you have all your
database access code and ensure your
development team only adds new code in
that module so you know exactly what
code talks the database and exactly what
code needs to be changed during the
migration process in general this is a
very good practice because it gives you
one single module to test your database
interactions and similarly it enables
your unit testing of your application we
only need one single modeled module to
mock out you don't need to have--you a
test database you don't need to have
some weird and wonderful way of creating
some some data that takes care of some
weird wonderful edge conditions you can
mock all that out and supply this bad
data to the rest of your application to
test how your application handles it it
makes it a lot easier to find and
analyze any complex sequel queries
you've got in your application
and it gives you a single point to add
metrics and alerts for monitoring your
database access for instance you could
add an alert for query latency so that
you know when your crews starting to get
a bit slow it's time to resize your
database add more power or you need you
see which query particular queries are
slow so you don't need to dive deeper
find out why they're slow maybe optimize
a query a bit better change the way
things are read perhaps also allows you
with metrics to check the frequency of
reads to the tables which may give you
an indication of whether you can add
some client-side caching to your
database layer thus giving a performance
boost to your applications it no longer
needs to read from the database and get
it from the local cache and of course
failure alerts so any read/write
failures any any inconsistency problems
you've got a place to alert it and catch
the pond before they start before the
starts getting really bad and as I said
you've got a single isolated module for
migration so your next step is to add
the code to that module that reads and
writes to spanner
sounds simple but we'll look into more
details about that later you'll be
reading and writing at the same time as
reading and writing from the original
database you would include capabilities
in your application that are not
available in spanner again more on that
later and code would be reading to and
writing from both at the same time but
you'd have one database as your source
of truth at the beginning of course if
the original database and once you've
fully migrated to your data over and
you're sure there's no inconsistencies
you can switch to cloud spanner as your
source of truth so rights when you're
right into a database take row you
should just ban that you should update
the entire row you shouldn't just update
the columns and that way you're ensuring
that the data are writing to spanner is
fully up to date on reads you can read
from both databases and compare any
inconsistencies and report those
inconsistencies
again this is to gain confidence that
your migration is happen correctly and
once your data is imported and
everything synchronized there should be
no inconsistencies and no more failures
one other thing you should be doing if
you do deletions of rows in your
database you should keep a log of these
when you're importing data and data my
rows might have already been deleted so
you don't have to be we creating these
rows you've already deleted whilst
you're doing your import keeping a log
of the deletions will allow you to check
whether this row has been deleted when
you're reinforcing it and finally one
really useful thing is commit timestamps
some databases do this automatically
spanner it's an option you have a column
which is the times time when that row is
being committed and you can use this to
know which is the latest date data
version whether it's the data you're
importing or it's the data that's
already been written by your application
to spanner and also this module one
other thing allows you to canary the use
of your new database you switch the
sources truth
partially you can star some application
instances talking to spanner and some
tokens original database so if you you
catch any problems early you can roll
back so how would you actually migrate
well simple method you convert your
database schema to cloud spanner schema
and create your database you shut down
your application you do your export and
import whilst your database is not being
written to so it's completely stable and
you start it up again this is not an
ideal path for several reasons firstly
there's no rollback your application if
you start noticing after a couple of
days things are going wrong some data's
getting corrupted what do you do you
can't roll back because you've got a
couple of days new data you can't fix
the data you can't you just like to
start panicking
if you roll back you've lost the data
and your problem and secondly your
application is down if you're moving to
spanner it's presumably because you want
to take advantage of the scalability and
the availability so you wouldn't want
the downtime associated with an export
and an import of a large data set so
what we do we want a live migration
process once again you start with the
same way you create original create your
database on cloud spanner and you export
an import from your original database to
spanner but this time you keep the
application stay running now of course
whilst your application is running your
exported data is already out of date
that's not a problem because we'll see
you write to both you keep the original
database as your source of truth and
continue updating rows and spanner there
will still be some instances
inconsistencies but that's why your
original database is still as
Sasa truth then whilst that's going on
you do another import and export of any
changes that have occurred since the
last export now this will bring your
data in sync provided that you only
write rows that haven't already been
updated so you also this point replay
any deletions that have occurred and
when this is completed we or it should
be that your cloud spanner database is
fully in sync with your original
database and the monitoring you've added
in your database access layer will not
be showing any more inconsistencies will
not be showing any more errors you can
repeat this last step as many times as
you want and at this stage you can also
run a massive compare to see which if
everything is in sync finally when
you're convinced everything is good not
finally sorry you switched to B this
cloud spanner as a source of truth again
like I mentioned before you can do this
as a canarian process you can partially
switch some application instances or a
percentage of the traffic and then
monitor things see if things good and
gradually increase the percentages that
has being written to cloud spanner and
if things go wrong you can immediately
rollback because your original database
is still being written you've got a
perfect rollback position to go to you
don't lose any data everything's fine
but if you've got if everything has gone
forward everything is working well and
everything's fixed then you can turn off
the code the rights to original database
turn off your additional database shut
it down and you're fully running on the
spanner and at this point of course you
have your launch party and you're back
to splats I mean now who will talk about
the example from migrating from a no
sequel database to a cloud spanner I
really wanted to have the party yeah
later later ok ok
migrating from no sequel so the obvious
thing here is that spanners known as a
sequel database but we have a lot of
customers and a lot of interest for
customers coming to us and saying hey
you know I made these design choices in
my application stack a while ago where I
couldn't scale in a relational database
a traditional relational database very
easily and so I had to
decide what I was going to give up and
most the time organizations chose to
give up transactional consistency hey
let's give up transactional consistency
because then we can shard really easily
or they decided you know it will
maintain a relational database but will
employ some sort of shim some sort of
sharding shim and so we're not really
getting true transactions across the
entire database in one context but we'll
have to sort of manipulate it and
introduce some plumbing in between so
really the point of this slide is that
you can have your cake and eat it too
spanner takes care of that it takes care
of that ongoing true horizontal
scalability while giving you
transactional consistency while giving
you the ability to stay high in terms of
to keep a very high uptime and then it
gets you back to a very simplistic model
where you're not having to deal with is
this key value is your document is it
you know what is the underlying storage
this is very simple to understand sequel
semantics so when does it apply so when
would you do this you wouldn't do this
for something that is highly volatile in
nature so if you're just keeping track
of the key and then you have an
arbitrary number of attributes
associated with that and it's really
hard for you to get a grasp of is there
a consistent is there a well-known
consistent pattern to the attributes
we're keeping track of with the thought
that those attributes would translate to
columns then this wouldn't be a pattern
for you to follow right this would be
really if you're like you know generally
we're using it as a way to keep track of
certain attributes the collection or the
set of those attributes is relatively
static maybe some attributes add here
there but that's okay we can do schema
changes within spanner but it's not too
it's not too varied it's not too all
over the place reasonably high volume
spanner is a running service which means
you instantiate a certain amount of
capacity to it so if you're only
transacting with the database at a
trickle volume it's some sort of light
lookup or something that's not it though
we use cases we're seeing our folks that
are saying you know I'm wholesale
running massively high transactional
throughput beyond beyond just a light
workload the source database should have
a pretty easy way I think most data
today we'll have a pretty easy way to
import and export data so you know much
like what Neal was mentioning not yet
much much like what Neal was mentioning
in in the import-export or mean the
migration general framework and the last
thing is it's a real plus
if the source system has some sort of
mechanism to do the equivalent of change
data capture if you can sort of know
what's coming in out of that database
it's great some source examples that we
we're seeing a lot of our folks that are
running their own [ __ ] infrastructure
own Cassandra infrastructure that also
sort of want to get out of that pattern
but also folks coming from more
traditional or more service main service
offerings like DynamoDB so we're gonna
pick one of these to walk through
migration anybody want to take a guess
right so dynamodb alright so it's pretty
straightforward it's a it's actually not
that complex DynamoDB is a single table
structure it's not it's not many tables
related to one it has some nice
interesting similarities with regards to
cloud spanner in terms of the way keys
are laid out but but it is a table and
we're going to go through a
straightforward path this kind of aligns
very nicely to what Neal was talking
about where we're gonna have a bulk
loading path that's going to come in
through certain export features and then
we'll have our trickle feeding or
streaming path will collate those on to
the blue icons or cloud Google Cloud
little basically coalesce those onto the
cloud side bring those together using a
technology on our side to call a product
called cloud dataflow and then they'll
make their way into Spanish so let's
build this together homework before you
get started is is to estimate how much
cloud spanner capacity we'll use
generally there are some rules of thumbs
regards to how much storage should be
allocated per any number of nodes so if
you think you'll be strained on the
storage side of things you would need to
scale up the number of nodes and so it's
basically a quota system of two
terabytes per node two terabytes per
node and so if you are gonna exceed that
you just want to kind of overshoot that
to
okay enough nodes to cover that if
you're well within that then you're
going to design on the side of
throughput and spanner which is how much
transactional throughput do I need which
is the second point is so now I know how
much storage I have how much IO do I
have on this database and then
understand the data model where am i
coming from so in the case of in the
case of a DynamoDB origination dinamo
has a couple choices for how it
structures its primary key is it hash or
is it hash plus range like we said in
the last slide then across all my items
in my table what are what is the
superset are the set of collection of
attributes so that I can understand how
to create my columns what are the data
types of those attributes and then also
keep track of any secondary indexes this
sort of if you do this as a worksheet or
as like I said as homework it sets you
up for a nice migration path first step
is understand the differences the data
types are generally there but there
could be some differences to understand
how data types from one map to the other
generally you're going to find all the
same data types if not more but
understood this is the canonical mapping
of data types so let's take a let's make
it practical let's start with a baseline
DynamoDB table this is a table you could
create it's using a simplistic hash key
as its as its primary key it's not using
hash and range and it's a hash key
called user name we have a little bit of
provision throughput and what I'm not
showing on here is that in order to
facilitate that streaming hook this
table would also have streams enabled
dynami to be streams which would just be
another flag on the end of this or you
could adjust your table if it's already
you have a table that's already running
you could simply argumented and add
streams to it so let's create the
equivalent table I'm sort of taking that
metadata I we went through in the
homework collection and we're going to
create the equivalent table and cloud
spanner and so let's say that we've
determined in that source table we've
looked at all the attributes inside of
our DynamoDB table and decided that
really there's just sort of four
consistent attributes our four
attributes that represent the majority
of what we're what we're looking at it's
like zips code subscribed you know
whether somebody subscribe to a feet or
not when they're there send sent a
reminder date maybe some points they
were and so this
fictitious table but it's probably not
too dissimilar from the way that you
would use a simple database or a
straightforward database like DynamoDB
that's more kind of key value oriented
so will might that nicely on to a cloud
scanner schema to get to that point kind
of in the beginning I alluded it's
actually really trivial this is almost
the entirety of what you have to get
going within cloud spanner is pick where
you want it how much capacity you want
and what you want to call it
if you hit create and I think we'll be
showing this later if you create it's a
few seconds a few seconds you've got
that much capacity sitting there and
Sona
and a 3-node regional set up this is
roughly 30,000 reads a second consistent
a 6,000 writes a second what's a lot of
capacity especially when you're talking
about maybe dealing with much lower
capacity in terms of provision
throughput just for three nodes you get
a lot and three nodes would be kind of
the minimum for a production size setup
there's also multi-regional which
implies more quorum copies and encourage
you to go to kind of a cloud spanner 101
talk to understand kind of how this the
quorum works and where the rights are
distributed but basically if you do this
within a few seconds you've got a
tremendous bucket of input output so
that table I showed on the previous
screen that said hey we've analyzed our
source table figured out how it looks in
dynamo figured out the columns how do we
map the columns to something database
oriented so within the instance so the
previous screen I showed how to create
an instance within that instance we can
now begin instantiating databases
databases are sort of logical containers
the instance is ubiquitous see of
capacity and then the databases are
specific logical units inside of that
database you can create tables looks and
feels pretty much like any other
database it's really not that dissimilar
but we take our DDL which is standard
DDL plug that in and create our database
one thing that we do at this point in
our table is we run back to our dynamo
table and using dynamodb streams and
lambda we want to capture all the
changes off and so I would turn around I
would make a function like this a lambda
function like this and this becomes the
glue between all the changes happening
inside of my dynamo
be table and all and getting it over to
the Google cloud side and we're using
basically pub/sub in the middle so
basically what I'm saying is inside of
my lambda function every time I get a
change I've got my dynamodb streams to
configure to send me the new image dinah
maybe you can say send me the old image
the new image or both and so all I'm
doing is I'm taking the entire payload
I'm just shoving it over and this
basically has lambda make a call and
sends it over to pub/sub will show
there's an action in a minute so it's in
pub sub pub sub is our highly scalable
distributed messaging system in which
case you know you can be pumping
messages in you know a million a second
or something ridiculous whatever your
application needs and have n number of
subscribers they can be pull subscribers
or push subscribers or something is
contacting and polling for messages or
it can push to an endpoint
any kind of endpoint like a cloud
function or whatnot we're gonna be using
a pull mechanism this would be an
interesting time if your application had
the luxury where you may this would be
the inflection point at which way you
may decide like hey for consistency's
sake let's do a quick pause while we
kick off and export it's not strictly
needed depending on how much data you
think is gonna be mutated during this
time or overlap of keys but this would
be that moment you would decide hey you
know we're gonna kick off an export
should we pause rights for a second
while so that we can keep track of
exactly when this lambda function it was
instantiated and when the export was
kicked off it's a momentary thing that
you would have to decide it's not
strictly needed so how do we get data so
we've already put in the lambda function
that's sending over the streaming data
basically now how do we do the bulk so
that becomes our checkpointing time like
put in this function we started
collecting data that's changing as of
this moment now how do we do the mass
export so you need to lean into the
platform that has that that host that
data source in the case of DynamoDB
there's a tool you can run a data
pipeline job that is the canonical way
to get data out if you were to go and
say export but what it does is it lands
that data into an s3 bucket it kicks off
an EMR process lost of MapReduce process
reaches in the table and then kicks out
flat files
that our JSON files and puts those into
an s3 bucket so if you think back to the
lambda function that lambda function was
our glue that got us from changes
happening in dynamo over two pub/sub if
you think about our s3 bucket the glue
that could have moves it from Amazon
side to the Google side is as a copy
command before you do the copy you just
kind of look at the bucket there should
be a success file inside of the export
that will tell you that everything went
correct but essentially you can use the
GS util it's a Google storage utility
that understands how to read Amazon
credential files so this is a very handy
feature that essentially let's say
you're working on an instance or you're
working inside a cloud shell and you've
installed the Amazon command line
utilities and obviously now the Google
command line utilities including GS util
GS util knows how to read your cameras
on credentials if you you know if
they're configured on the same box and
you can literally pass it in s3 URL so
in this case I can say go from the s3
bucket to my Cloud Storage bucket and an
R sync so just tell me everything that's
there especially large transfer we have
a background operation called cloud
storage transfer service that will do
this for you in the background and then
on now both sets of artifacts both the
pubsub streaming changes as well as the
flat files from s3 or sitting or have
have shown up on the Google side of the
fence so what do we do with those things
the first thing is we do a a job to
import all those flat files from s3 so
we're gonna we would kick off a dataflow
job and data flows are managed service
for managing Apache beam pipelines so we
would have a pipeline written an Apache
beam pipeline that knows how to take
flat files and JSON format and write
those into cloud spanner using something
called spanner IO which is a mechanism
for Apache beam to write to spanner and
that would run through and that would
complete and this is the nice thing
about cloud dataflow is it takes your
Apache beam pipeline and then gives you
this very kind of introspective view
into your pipeline how it is and how
much you know how many messages are
being written what was the success
factor and so you would monitor the
progress verify item counts when it's
done perhaps do some selects between the
two data
is and make sure that the item count
between one table and another table are
the same and do some spot checking kind
of look at an item and one look at the
item in in one database and look at the
item another one you're going to want to
do this may be four different items
inside of your inside of your database
so now the more interesting challenge
which is how do you get those streaming
changes which have been getting into the
pub sub-q which haven't been picked up
yet how do we get those out and pushed
into spanner so now we want to create a
subscription to that want to create a
subscription to that topic and run the
same thing but this is now a streaming
job this will not terminate like the
other job which was a batch job this is
a streaming job that kicks off and it's
very similar this is a dag structure
which is like essentially a structure of
activities that you've asked to happen
in a sequence and now the streaming
pipeline will stay in in continuum it's
not going to terminate because you
expect messages to keep coming in until
the migration is done right and note
this does it's slightly different it's
it's not just new records it's it has to
look and see is this a kradin are an
update and or a delete this is because
the spanner API calls that do these are
slightly different and so you need to
separate this logic so I've shown you
some dataflow code I don't want to make
this slide a texture so let's show you
some some of the background behind it so
let's look at the batch pipeline it's a
little more concise for purpose of
demonstration but this is Apache Beam
code this is a kind of a trim down
version of the pipeline you create these
pipelines and you essentially just
create these stages within your pipeline
and this is a pretty straightforward one
you can annotate it with sort of a
friendly name that will be represented
in the UI but I want to read items I
want to parse items I want to create
mutations and write items sounds pretty
sounds like kind of the canonical
activities that you would go through and
let's look at one of these let's look at
like parse items which is basically how
do I take that incoming JSON that's
coming from the records that are coming
from dynamo and how do how do I map
those what's that what is that step that
just said parse items in my Apache bean
pipeline what that's doing is its
mapping it to a Java object in this case
and so you would have some code that
says hey map JSON which JSON with JSON
and
got this object representation of each
record that's coming through so now that
I've got each record that's coming
through the next thing in my pipeline
list was create new tations create
mutations takes each of these class
members now and sort of lets me map them
into column names so that was the second
this was the second step in that
pipeline and so once that's done then
basically that's that's pipeline has
what it needs one thing I'll touch on is
the Dynamo we mentioned that could
happen could have a slightly different
primary key structure which would be
hash and range this is where you would
take advantage of a feature within
spanner cloud spanner called interleaved
tables where one table can be nested
inside of another table by attribution
of a commonly shared primary key or the
first part of a primary key so if you
notice these boats share say username as
a primary key but also order number this
physically co-locate s-- data that's
like and fro so the for the primary key
was neal and then the next thing was
Neil and his orders those would be sort
of co-located from a storage perspective
they would be operated on by the same
nodes within spanner or they would be
technically being the same split so to
be managed by the same nodes this makes
things like co-located this makes things
like co-located joins very fast and
efficient also secondary indexes if you
remember the original interrogation was
are there any secondary indexes any
indexes on non primary key fields you
would turn around and now at the end
would be the time to apply that and
spanner does the same thing if you don't
have a secondary index and you scan you
ran a query on a non primary key field
you're essentially going to get a full
table scan coming back at you so we want
to create a secondary index on whatever
columns we're going to be interesting to
our query so I'll do a quick little
run-through on verifying replication
this is demo time so this is usually
when the sweat beads start so if we
could all right so to be respectful of
time I'm going to just sort of run
through some trivial I'm gonna create
three keys I'm gonna MA I'm gonna deal
with three keys in my dining with table
I'm gonna have my add key my change key
and my delete key I'm just gonna so the
add one I'm going to add in see if it
comes over to space
the change 1 I'm going to change an
attribute in the delete 1 I'm gonna get
rid of I'm gonna basically see those
happen and then walk through everything
that happened so let's just verify a few
things number one is I don't have any I
don't have a key I don't have the add
key that's the one I'm about to add in
let's look at the key I'm going to
change key I'm going to change right now
is currently set to false and so anybody
want to take a guess of what I'm going
to change it to true
all right and then lastly is I'm going
to run delete and so there's a record
there that we're gonna wipe away all
right so let's go and mess with these
things on dynamo side so I'm in my
dynamo table the first thing is I'm
gonna just add my add key and I'm gonna
add boolean and cold subscribe and I'm
gonna call it false so let's add that
and I'm gonna also then modify
oh I'm gonna change this key if you
remember it's set to true or false is it
true
it's gonna change this key and the last
thing is I'm gonna modify I'm gonna get
rid of okay so these are kind of the
canonical crud operations right what
would happen if I changed what it would
happen if I thing okay so I've changed
everything on this side so let's look at
our lambda function real quick so our
dynamo table is set up to have a trigger
this trigger is DynamoDB spanner lambda
function that showed earlier and this is
that function some things I'd point out
is that that function obviously needs to
operate with some credentials in order
to talk to the Google API is those
credentials don't belong in flat files
or any sort of extractable measure
you're going to want to set those as
environment variables for your lambda
function and you would take the entire
service account JSON and shove that in
as has an environment variable for your
function let's say in this case service
account that is in fact not my service
account JSON okay and then let's check
cloud watch and see if any logs came
through so is that about the right time
that things came through so this was the
add the key I added that time stamp
should be about right now I added my key
and you can see that basically new image
straying my ID my key boolean false and
then this is the key thing to pay
attention to is pub/sub ID so that's the
lambda function having contacted Google
pub/sub and the Google pub/sub API
saying here's your pub/sub ID back and
basically my change key you can see that
the old image was or the new image is
true the old image is false and my
delete key you can see that it was a
remove and it was removed okay so in
cloud dataflow this pipeline is running
actually I should have shown that but
this is currently running so this
pipeline is consistently running I
should have shown that counts beforehand
but I missed that step but in the logs
of this you can see that basically the
logging for pub/sub says hey three keys
came by my way and so what it did is it
ran for each of those keys that ran
through this pipeline so that's already
done let's see if we go back through so
before we had a key here my delete key
no results found so that's been wiped
away that was the key we delete it out
my change key what did I change it to
true right I flipped it from close to
true and the other is add and it's there
so so that's that's effectively the
entirety of that pipeline it's actually
a really really simple pipeline
something you could orchestrate pretty
pretty easily you plan to plant publish
it as a solution so that folks can
download it and try their own so that's
it for me I'm going to hand it over to
new
okay so Sammy is showing you how to use
data flow as a streaming pipeline making
sure your changes go from dynamo to
spanner I'm going to do the big job
which is the bulk import creating the
spanner instance and int rating and
importing all the data so like we said
for clicks to click create spanner I'm
going to create an instance I'm going to
use the music brains
yep spelled correctly database anything
you can figure it in my home country
you're at West one which is Belgium but
you've been inside that data center it
is massive i I was expecting it to be a
big but it was bigger so we create
twenty nodes this will give us a
database that will be able to handle 40
terabytes of data two hundred thousand
reads per second and forty thousand
writes per second and it's a bigger than
what we need for musicbrainz database
but it's for getting the demos happening
speedily here we have our DDL which is
simple create table you can see here
that I'm using a commits timestamp on
that row and there's primary keys I'm
using a hashed ideas the initial primary
key I'll explain that in the next
section so I'm just going to copy paste
this into my spanner creation continue
editors text BAM and create and this is
my fourth click so that creates my
database and thank you and there I have
100 and something tables that are in the
musicbrainz database so now I want to
import my data well musicbrainz already
puts all their data on their website as
tabbed eliminated format export files so
I put all those already in a cloud
storage bucket
I've written a dataflow job as Siamese
explained with all the steps and I'm now
going to run that dataflow job to pull
the files frob in the source path from
this cloud storage bucket and putting it
in this new database that I've just
created so just copy that and run it and
this simple build runs depth of maven
and it started and in a couple of
seconds it will initiate the dataflow
job
- starting bulk importing the data yep
but there goes in theory there we go so
this dataflow job as Sammy explained
earlier graphic still being analyzed
there we go so it looks at this cloud
storage bucket gets the list of files to
import it reads the tab delimited format
files gets each line which is a single
row in in the original database you
create the spanning mutation passing the
data in that row converting it to the
spanner types and then because it's a
batch job I'm going to batch these
mutations together in groups of a
hundred and and then write these batches
of a hundred to spanner it's more
efficient to write batches of rows to
spanner they just write individual rows
and this job is now running its dataflow
uses compute engine VMs and you can see
here if i refresh that page it's created
a bunch of VMs there we go a bunch of
VMs to run those data flow steps each of
those boxes can be run on individual
nodes with dataflow managing the data
passing between one and the other and it
will Rialto scale high and low to two
and it's just going there so it's read
so far 78 files 234 files and it's
starting to read them so okay we'll let
that go running and we'll come back to
the end of the next section so Sammy
talked about no sequel and I mean after
run through as quickly because we've got
less time when we thought we had I mean
talked about no sequel I'm gonna be
talking about the relational database
side import my deep may examples would
be my sequel specific but the general
case applies to most relational
databases so Sammy's already talked
about why and the advantages are
reasonably obvious no planned downtime
no ops everything that's managed for you
operating system hardware and software
updates happen all in the background
horizontally scaled so you can just add
more power when you want to no sharding
you've got a globally consistent view of
your data and external consistency with
acid compliant right transactions
read transactions allow you to read data
at a particular time stamp up to an hour
old and you've got all scott and c 2011
sequel queries
so the first thing want to do is look at
your existing schema and check the data
types
spanner has a very concise set of data
types there's just this little bunch
here all of these can be actually used
as keys apart from the array type the
array type can you have any of the other
types so you want to look at your
existing schema and map the existing
data types to the cloud spanner data
types many of them have a direct mapping
but some of them as you can see in this
list do not have a direct mapping in
this case you want to change the
application database access layer like
we mentioned earlier to convert from
your internal representation to an
equivalent spanner representation so for
instance an email you'd write that to
spanner as a string and you pass it back
out and theum in your application table
keys are an important consideration of
spanner in traditional databases you
often work with sequences where your
rows increase just constantly that is an
anti-pattern a spanner
because spanner splits the data in into
multiple splits sorted by primary key
and when you add data it's added to the
split so if you've got a sequential key
always increasing it'll always be added
to the last split and if you're doing
that a lot then your last bit becomes
the only split where there's any
database activity becomes a hotspot and
you may have 20 nodes but you're only
using one to write your data so what do
you do about this well you need to
prefix your keys with another key in
order to distribute the data better now
if it was a a Greenfield database you
probably use a unique UID or random key
but because we're importing we want to
keep this sequential key so what do we
do well we add a hash we simply do a
simple hash of the original key and
prefix that in the span of primary case
you see on the second row the primary
key has a hashed ID which in this case
of just on a crc32 it doesn't have to be
secure it just has to be somewhat random
but deterministic based on the original
ID there is lots of documentation on
google comm about how to hash keys and
other date details in which to avoid
hotspots in cloud spanner by by using
these this feature
of course if you have referential keys
you need to include the hash key in the
reference because it's the primary key
of the existing table so you need to
include the hash key in the referenced
table this is to avoid a full-scale
table scan when you're wanting to look
up the keys when you do a join once the
application has been fully migrated you
can do another migration if you want to
which is to remove all the sequences and
such everything to unique you IDs
secondary indexes in spanner are also
implemented by tables under the hood so
the exact trade problem occurs with
columns you've got an index in this case
we're indexing events by timestamp
timestamp of courses are continuously
increasing in key and you'll get a
hotspot because you're adding more and
more events increasing in time so
getting a hotspot what do you do here
well you do have something called
application-level sharding which is
creating a shard ID this is not the same
as a split ID it's just an application
defined value to mix up the data a bit
in this case I'm using the crc32 of the
timestamp modular 100 which gives you a
number from naught to 99 which is
relatively random based on the time
stamp
I had this into the table and I index on
that timestamp shard ID so that way the
index itself is randomly distributed if
I want to select from that index using a
range select I have to include all the
shards because otherwise again because
it's the key saina will do a table scan
so again I'm selecting using the between
floors they're shards not to 99 and then
using the range clause and that gives a
limited Select and not a full table scan
sequences do not exist in clouds banette
because as I said it's an anti-pattern
so for that you have to implement them
in your application the simplest way is
to have a table in your database called
sequences with a sequence name and the
next identifier when you want to add a
row to your table you get the next ID
you increment it and update your
sequences table and then you insert your
new row with the obviously the hashed ID
and the new sequence number this is fine
for a rarely modified table but if
you've got something happening a lot
this of course becomes a choke point
every every insert where we have to wait
on the sequences table to do the update
we've gone a bit too far for myself
there so the way to avoid that would be
to get each application instance manage
a block of sequences so the read say 100
sequences from the table manage them
internally issuing issuing the sequence
IDs to itself it means you'll lose the
continuous value of the sequence to a
certain degree but as said continuous
keys are not the best plan in spanner in
any case foreign key constraints spanner
gives a lot of performance benefits by
trusting the application to keep the
data consistent and one of these things
is not having foreign key constraints in
other tables this you can have to
implement in the application if you want
it but in most applications it already
knows what data is there what data isn't
there and so you wouldn't be able to
create applications shouldn't be able to
create an object without the parent
object already existing if you do want
to add foreign key constraints you can
easily do it yourself in the database
access layer simply by checking for the
existence of a reference table key and
if it doesn't exist throw an exception
and if it does then you insert your row
and there's a foreign key constraint
check implemented application side
similarly on delete and on update rules
must also be implemented in the
application because there's no foreign
key constraints you find all the child
IDs that are referenced by the parent
you delete them all and then you delete
your parent on that's a non delete
cascade rule of course on delete update
or on delete set now Knowle would be
implemented by updating the rows or
abandoning transactions should any child
rows be there as some you already
mentioned the interleaved parent-child
relationship does have referential
integrity constraints and on delete
rules so here we have a parent and a
child we've told it to interleave and
the parent on delete cascade Sammy's
mentioned in detail about that I'm gonna
just skip over it but in this case there
is a foreign key constraint and the
child table key must reference the key
of the parent and in a non-league
cascade rule you delete the parent at
least the children you can create a
hierarchy of six levels of tables in
this manner but
because all the child tables have to be
in the same split as a top-level row the
four gigabytes size split live it
applies the size of the top-level row
and all its children that hasn't
happened very often but I have had a
customer that thought they would meet
that problem commit timestamps I
mentioned you define them in the schema
with an options clause in application
you use a special value to insert the
commit timestamp and then you can use
that during the migration process to
detect whether a row has later or
earlier data I'm really rushing through
this because I can see the clock
counting down quite rapidly other things
that you'd have to mention on the
application side default values easy to
put in your in your database access
layer stored procedures and triggers
well due to the distributed architecture
triggers a bit of an anti-pattern you
can easily implement in your application
and because spanner is effectively
infinitely scalable you don't have a
worry about running triggers and stored
procedures and the database you just
have more more nodes and everything runs
better it also gives you the benefit
that the stored procedures and triggers
you're putting your business logic in
the application with the rest of the
code and you can have written in the
same language you can unit test it and
without needing a test database instance
per table access privileges don't exist
in spanner your access control is read
or write for the using the cloud
platform I am controls for the whole
database and finally sorry go back JDBC
it's currently read-only and there is no
data modification language currently but
right at this moment there is a second
spanner talk going on over in Moscow any
size where Deepti are clarence minus PM
is announcing that data modification
language is being previewed right now
and there'll be a readwrite JDBC wrapper
coming soon okay we got a a minute or so
left so let's have a look at my demo and
see if everything is run okay so back to
the dataflow view what have we got
so we've read 234 source files from that
we've got 20 million records achieve
adding to span at the rate of 31,000 per
second batching them of course down to
300 batches per second or so and have a
look at the logged failures there have
been no failures and 21 million
successes and just to show that this is
for real I'm going to go stop this jobs
to get my database of rest where are we
spanner let's have a look at the artists
credit table and let's have a look at
some of the data so here when the data
finally comes out you lose mana the demo
gods are not smiling on me with 20
seconds counting down on the clock there
we go so here we see that the data has
been added the original sequential IDs
have been prefixed by a hash and
therefore being completely mixed up in a
random order and if I just want to run a
query on that data will run a simple
query selecting all the recordings that
have the word cloud in their name
joining them with the artist and see
what we get out query but there we go
this one is query this when I tested it
yesterday took about five seconds
because it's a demos but we're going to
take ten times as long and we can be
sitting here talking to myself for five
minutes yeah so once the query comes
back having you scanned its several
million rows because of course I'm not
using an index key I'm using a table
scan on the name okay what we'll do is
we'll let that run which because the
demo gods are obviously not smiling on
me would run through a quick last couple
of slides and we'll come back to this so
other things wrap up tomorrow there's a
talk on how nest camera services moved
to Google clouds they originally on
Amazon when Google acquired them and
they've just completed a massive
migration so all the camera services all
your recordings on néstor now on Google
Cloud Niantic are going to talk about
moving to cloud spanner and now antic
other people behind
Ingres and pokemon go and reinventing
databases for your journey through the
cloud in the archives from yesterday
there is opti ver who migrated from
Oracle to cloud and there lessons
learned bandai namco how they using
cloud spanner and the session that i
just mentioned
see what's new with cloud spanner which
is happening right this minute in a
restart my query because it appears to
have got stuck just to annoy me
and finally quote from opt eva when they
move from Oracle to spanner they could
process ten times more transactions at
one tenth of the cost so they're
obviously very happy with migration from
all codes banner one other thing I just
like to announce is tomorrow which is
cloud hero
it's a and I here's my cape because I am
apparently a cloud hero
it's a develop style game where you race
against the clock to meet a section of
challenges so I now have my cape and if
we go back to the demo it has finally
finished its query we have a bunch of
tracks with their artists who I have
never heard of before and and there we
go that's basically covered it we've
gone a little bit over time I'm sorry
about that if you have any questions how
much time do we have left
no just fine it's okay thank you okay
[Applause]
you
[Music]